next question today is from Erin Erin
says regarding the documentary poverty
Inc I realize that they don't address
medical assistance to these countries
what's your opinion on missionary
doctors how useful are organizations
such as doctors without borders is
providing free health care to countries
with the need of the service eventually
detrimental to the very same countries
yet so background I recommended the film
poverty inc and what poverty Inc exposes
is that many times a lot of the efforts
you see from companies and NGOs to help
other countries in the long term may not
be that useful and an example was not to
pick on them but Tom's footwear donates
a pair of shoes to a poor country for
every pair that is sold or something
like that and the argument is listen
it's great that people who don't have
shoes are getting some shoes but when
you're just donating shoes on an every
once in a while basis to these countries
you're really not allowing you're
actually preventing the local shoe
making industry from flourishing and if
you take a step back our country is
going to get out of poverty if some
other company from another country sends
shoes for the people there or are they
going to do a better job of of trying to
raise themselves out of poverty if they
develop a supply and demand economy
internally wear shoes are both being
purchased and people can afford buying
shoes that that's a sort of big-picture
argument the question from Aaron is okay
given that we understand that what about
medical assistance in countries like
Doctors Without Borders etc I think it's
a little different because I think that
of course it would be far more desirable
for countries to be able to advance and
develop and sustain their own systems of
Medicine and being able to treat disease
prevent disease and administer medicine
on their own however there is a more
long-term benefit to coming in and
bringing in Doctors Without Borders or
medical care or vaccines or whatever
insofar as if you're saving people from
death
preventable disease by sending vaccines
from another country for example you now
have a much larger population base that
can innovate and can work and can
purchase etcetera etcetera so missionary
doctors I did disagree with in principle
because you're sort of manipulating
people in you're saying hey we're here
to save you and by the way we're really
here it's not actually just the vaccines
or the treatment of the technology we
bring but it's also Jesus or you know
Mormonism or whatever the case may be so
I am I don't like the idea of missionary
doctors to the extent that any doctors
are willing to go and provide medical
services I think that's a good thing but
from from a sort of a cultural
perspective I don't like the whole
missionary doctor think I'll give you a
vaccine and he'll tell you about Jesus
Christ